mais vous m'avez parlé comme si j'étais
le président du burkina faso mais moi je
ne veux pas m'occuper de l'électricité
dans les universités quelque part vous
ne parlez comme si j'étais toujours une
puissance coloniale mais moi je ne veux
pas m'en occupais d'électricité dans les
universités l'impasse
c'est le travail c'est le travail du
président
alors par contre alors qu'approche vous
rassure du puissant voire installant
du coup ils partirent est réparé la
climatisation
mais plus sérieusement plus sérieusement
vous l'avez compris je suis pour que
chacun fasse ce qu'il doit faire au bon
endroit et donc je ferai tout pour aider
à ce qu'ils les conditions pour aller
dans ce sens mais chacun sol
voilà merci de vos questions